yeah okay good job you have good job all
done hi everyone my name is Kristen I
have an eleven month old son named Wyatt
and I'm really excited because we're
going to teach him sign language for a
week why it seems to get frustrated
easily when he can't communicate with us
outside of him pointing at things I
think it's really good to be able to
have actual words and description only
good can come from it if I were going to
bet I would say he'll learn at least
three signs I don't think anyone will
learn in a week who's teaching we all
her you can tell the way he's pointing
he repeats as much as he can so I think
he is just very anxious to have a way to
communicate with us so I think it's
gonna be fun okay wait
you do more more you do more do you want
more food like this more MORE every kid
is so different that you kind of have to
tailor the words that you're teaching to
them to what makes sense for them look
what you want more yeah good job I had
to go and this morning to a meeting with
a client so we had our nanny here and I
showed her some of the signs we were
doing she's like my mom this is so much
work that a busy life and an on-the-go
life does make it difficult to get this
done in a week and it feels like I'm
being unfair to him if I'm not giving it
110% or my husband is not or whoever
else is around him I'm finding that it's
actually easier not to so much focus on
specific words but instead try and find
times where there there are like good
teachable moments and he's sitting down
and eating he's looking at me he's
making eye contact it's almost like
we're bartering where I'm like okay try
and do more and he'd get some things
when we're doing things like trying to
play with him I keep trying to say ball
or book or Walker it's a little more
difficult because it's it's hard to be
playing with him while using my hands
and he's playing with the actual object
and it's not I don't want to just take
it away from him yeah he's kind of
already saying some other words which
makes it a little tricky so it makes it
difficult to basically like try and
convince him to use
he's like hey mom I can say this word
still a good possibility because it's
not like he's speaking in full sentences
we're not supposed to let him play with
toys while he eats breakfast or any meal
but I think he's not feeling great today
he's a little bit of a cough so I'm a
softy and I'm giving him but I will say
it makes it incredibly to sign yeah I
found that any distractions wins I
didn't make it ah basically impossible
Wyatt do you want more food more I try
and teach him and if he you know doesn't
get it but like it is in the middle of
eating like I know that he wants more
food and I just feel like a bad mom if
I'm just not giving it to him so I don't
know I think that that obviously makes
it difficult that I'm too easy on him
day four and the struggle is real I have
to be honest
sign language is kind of taking a
backseat today you know mom life what
can you do you can't plan for so much I
feel like I can plan for like half-hour
increments basically and then you just
have to be flexible I think him not
feeling great you know made me want to
again keep him happy and
so day four did not go as planned but
there's always day five right yeah okay
good job you have a good job all done he
did start to somewhat sign all done I
think the reason is with all the other
signs so far he's either able to say the
word or he knows like for example with
more he can pick up his own food and eat
more or he knows that will give him more
food when he's done eating I think he is
like I am done eating like get this away
from me
overall I still got one word and that is
like amazing
day six Wyatt went to his grandparents
house today he did not learn sign
language but he did have a great time I
think in the beginning of the week I was
like oh he really wants to communicate
and he gets frustrated and this will
help us communicate and by the end of
the week I've kind of realized like
we're actually really great at
communicating yeah that's right that's a
ball good job this experience has been
awesome in terms of realizing how close
we are and how much we understand each
other and I love that final day what do
you think why I think so too
he was fun we just found you know what
kind of what formula works best for
Wyatt and I think that's a great point I
think if any lesson that we learned from
this it's that you know every kid is so
different as I've altered do you need to
communicate with your kid the way that
works best for that but clearly we have
someone here who likes to talk
[Music]